uh and you know I don't know if because
it's closer to the end of the year will
get more positive calls or more negative
calls let's see our next caller from the
989 area code what's your name and where
you calling from hi this is a crisp from
Michigan Chris what's on your mind today
and I just had a quick a quick comment i
bought these can bond headphones on your
recommendation and when I when I when
they arrived I saw that they were made
in China I was just wondering for an
explanation about that most electronics
in the US are made in China that's the
explanation I wish I had something else
I'm sure Trump will bring them back and
they'll be made in the united states
that you know okay okay well I guess I
just trusted your progressive research
to make sure they were made in a place
that wasn't used like with child labor
so what mobile I do you not us Krispy
respondent patent Chris what's your menu
Samsung okay where's that made it's a
samsung phone and the headphones work
great make no mistake about that I just
I bought them because I thought they
wouldn't be made like well I guess I
have no problem with people making them
to China they get good they get paid
well okay but uh I got that that's the
case but it's the same thing as your
Samsung narrator you have all buckled in
he seems like he doesn't have a
conversation about this is weird I don't
know if you've noticed but basically all
electronics are made in China uh sort of
an odd call but clearly an agenda and
also seemingly on some kind of a delay I
don't know though those uh I was very
odd thanks for watching this video
before you watch the next one remember
we're raising money to expand the david
pakman show big league as well as expand
progressive activism go to david
pakman.com slash donate donations of any
size are much appreciated